my name is markiplier I'm here joined by
ether this is Tyler who are you he
passed he pass you know when I was a
child I couldn't afford to do his race
we couldn't even afford eggs we have a
chicken but then we had to kill it for
our own entertainment
I've never tie-dyed anything in my life
we really never know I grew up poor like
we couldn't even afford shirts let alone
color so we're gonna be doing something
nice something really like fun it's more
of a craft thing it's smoke some grass
you call he pass German was it me boss
piss ass ass try to make a shockmount
measuring is for [ __ ] I am a penis
you like me to put yours on slave video
you guys have to have some sort of gift
or clip that makes it super sexual you
got to knock it out before you
[Music]
we haven't got the tie dye yet
after doing this nothing my nails are
just all this goes you want to live fast
fall he passes wieners microwave a break
your face never thought about any
decision I've ever made
[Laughter]
Oh
Oh guys you're not listening stop mixing
just dry powder what is this what is
this what what is this well it says that
what we don't you dare talk to he pass
like that you're right oh good gets so
many bits of paper in mine but here's
something that others don't know we're
gonna make these shirts but we're not
gonna do it with our eyes we're gonna do
it with our souls like making love you
don't do with your eyes you don't do it
your body do with your heart you gotta
know about time someone knows
[Laughter]
good there's multiple colors in this one
I'm sorry specifically fell in the
definition of burgeoning one ooh
virgins in the field one who likes to
burgeon themselves so glad I trade for
all your improv lessons oh and you don't
have a feeling in your pie you don't
have it why are you still over there why
are you you guys are all dying to see
though you're doing good we're dying
I've been bad this Easter do it again oh
you do not meet you we don't have time
to go around anywhere kindly use your
inside voice you pass your oh you can't
just say things are okay in there okay
[Laughter]
[Music]
no I don't know have my fingers leap
through mine
doubled in size my freaking huge huge
lair it's time to Avenger brother Barry
[Laughter]
no you have to start over right and I
know you're you're at the advantage if
you're gone that's ambidextrous no
mixing anything no it isn't it is
distinctly different altogether of it
being the same thing say aye
it's not i'll post me the only person
who has the right to vote in this all
right well the only person with the
right to vote didn't vote correctly they
said me instead of nay the motion has
passed that was democracy in action
just because you democracy is a failure
as a government that's all you bottoms
here first who knows maybe this tastes
really good
I don't think so you fill this up with
water please
hey stop rubbing cut it up get some help
thank you everybody so much for watching
this has been another markiplier makes
they're slowly getting out of my control
I won't be able to contain the beasts
for much longer run while you still have
life in your loves and thank you me for
being Who I am and having the patience
and grace to deal with these two idiots
beside me thanks again for watching and
as always see you in the next video
buh-bye